[Musik]
ihre aufgabe als innenminister ist es
jetzt ja die zu schnappen die das ganze
zeug auch gekauft haben konsumiert haben
schnappen sie die eine ganz schwere
frage
wir werden garantiert wie alle erwischen
und ich sage ihnen im moment ist auch
die priorität darauf gerichtet erstens
denen die wir jetzt erwischt haben die
ist ja selber betrieben haben zu
verurteilen zu bringen und zweitens noch
mögliche weitere täter und das
allerwichtigste möglich weitere kinder
zu finden denn jeden tag den wir
schneller sind wird ihr ein kind davor
bewahrt weiter missbraucht zu werden und
insofern ist dass die priorität
die berge sind so groß dass polizei
garantiert nicht alles auf einmal machen
kann und da muss man priorisieren und
die priorisierung heißt erst der
missbrauch möglichst schnell weitere
täter erwischen möglichst weit möglich
weitere opfer sehen und sie raus ziehen
und dann am schluss werden wir uns
wahrscheinlich um die frage kümmern wer
hat denn das alles noch konsumiert denn
das sind ja wie gigantische anzahl bei
kinderpornographie da fängt bei mir
schon an
da bin ich schon unsicher ob man
überhaupt von kinderpornografie reden
darf denn wir stellen immer öfter fest
so war das ja hier auch erst war dass
kinderpornographie das rangierte nicht
so ganz vorne
und je mehr mandaten bekamen die mehr
ist man dann dahinter gekommen dass das
auch missbrauch war also sehr häufig ist
so dass jemand der kinderpornografisches
material konsumiert irgendwann nur in
den chats bleiben kann wenn er selber
liefert und genau das ist der teil der
die sache unheimlich beschleunigt
vermehrt und wie immer mehr solche fälle
haben und insofern ich kann nur sagen
müssen alles ernst nehmen auch wenn wir
priorisieren müssen weil man nicht alles
gleichzeitig machen kann
[Musik]